[موسيقى]
صناديق كبيره وناقله بريه وبحريه واوراق
كثيره هكذا كان يتم تناقل الرسائل قبل ان
ياتي يا ريتم لينسون ويحول الصناديق
الصلبه الى مجلدات على صفحات الالكترونيه
تنقل الكلمات والمجلدات والوثائق من مكان
الى اخر حول العالم تحت مسمى بات معروف
لدى الجميع البريد الالكتروني فكيف تم
اختراعه
بدات رحله اختراع البريد الالكتروني في
الستينيات القرن الماضي من خلال ارسال
الرسائل داخل شبكه من الحواسيب ولعل نظام
ميل بوكس الذي استخدم بمعهد يوسف
للتكنولوجيا كان بمثابه ارضيه لهذا
الاختراع لكن البدايه الفعليه جاءت على يد
مهندس الحاسوب لينسون في عام
1971 عندما انشا نظام لنقل رسائلي داخل
شبكه عامه واستخدم الرمز ات كرمز لتسميه
العناوين تم استخدامه نظام الجديد من خلال
ربط المستخدمين على شبكه وكاله مشروعات
الابحاث المتقدمه الامريكيه ارفانات حيث
كان يعمل تومسون من قبل وزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه قبل ان يبدا التفكير في تبادل
المنظمات المختلفه الرسائل بينها
فطور زميلاتهم لينسون لاري روبرت وجون
فيدال امكانيه سرد الرسائل وتحديدها
واعاده توجيهها والرد عليها واضاف برامج
لتنظيم البريد الالكتروني فاصبح لدى
البنات المئات من المستخدمين العسكريين
في عام
1976 كانت الملكه اليزابيث الثانيه اول
رئيس دوله يقوم بارسال رساله بريد
الكترونيه من خلال شبكه البنات
ومعبد الاستخدام المدني تم انتاج الحديد
من الانظمه البريديه بدا من تطبيق
الذي استخدم واجهه الرسميه
مرورادس
منه اكثر من ثلاثه الاف و 500 نسخه عام
بحلول منتصف التسعينيات دخلت الشركات
الكبرى في سباق المنافسه على اصدار
تطبيقات بميزات اعلى فطرحت مايكروسوفت
تطبيق انترنت ميل اند نيوز الذي تمت اعاده
تسميته لاحقا باسم اوتلوك
بدورها قدمت هوتميل خدمه البريد
الالكتروني المرجانيه قبل ان تستحوذ عليها
شركه مايكروسوفت في عام
1998 على مدى السنوات القليله التاليه
شكلت امريكا اون لاين
مشهد الانترنت والبريد الالكتروني
في اواخر التسعينيات اصبح هناك 400 مليون
مستخدم وبدخول الالفيه اصبح امتلاك حسابي
بريد الكتروني ضروره عند مستخدم الشبكه
العنكبوتيه اليوم ورغم ما تتيحه شبكه
الويب العالميه من تطبيقات متقدمه يظل
البريد الالكتروني احد اهم التطبيقات
والاكثر استخداما دوليا
[موسيقى]